hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga and 19:11 tournament of
san sebastian or as someone
well corrected me in the comments it's
obviously not san sebastian it sounds
Sebastiaan or as the locals call it the
most yeah I might even mean something if
there's anyone watching from San
Sebastiano
you can all also share some other cool
stuff about where you live in the
comments as we all enjoy learning new
things about getting back to this game
after his his draw in round 4 against
dr. Siebert are sure he faces davi
deunov ski or maybe it's John off ski
heart the same one of the leading polish
Czech chess masters and about double
Janoski he has been an extremely
successful tournament player but
throughout his career he mostly had
better success with the older generation
of players rather than younger gentlemen
and also as this is played in 1911 in
1910 he finally got his opportunity to
face Emanuele asked her in in a match
for the title but in that in that match
something that something simply wasn't
going his way out of the lot of all the
games they played Alaska won eight to
zero so Janoski did not win a single
game against emmanuel ask her they drew
three games so he definitely also wants
to well get back out there and the
distant is just the place to do it and
who better to you know show his prowess
than the great Cuban host a roll kappa
blanka so let's let's check out this
very nice game Capablanca opens with d4
we have d5 and III Knight to f6
we have 933 c5 and c4 e6 we have Knight
to c3 and now with a bit of a different
order of moves we reach the tower
defense Bishop to e7 and now comes D
captures on c5 this is always something
you will very often see white it doesn't
wanna capture on c5 before black
actually develops the bishop now only
after black develop the bishop now
capablanca captures so black has to play
another move
with a piece he already played with so
little captures on c5 would be losing
the tempo so for now black just castles
we have 8 3 by Capablanca maybe
preparing before to solidify his
opponent c5 so now Bishop captures on c5
and before kicking the bishop back
Bishop to e7 and now comes the Bishop to
b2 so already quite a few moves played
by this a bishop to e7 that's why in
modern times first the black will wait
to see what white will do in the center
before deciding to develop the vision
and okay as a couple are already
expended quite nicely on the Queen side
we have a 5 attacking the b4 pawn here
black wants to free his rook and why not
you want to open lines as much as
possible capablanca skin is still in the
center not anywhere near castling safety
so b5 Capablanca prefers to keep it
closed and now b6 we have C capture son
b 5e capture son d5 and now we're
Knights to d4 grabbing more space also
this night might be interested you know
coming to c6 would be a very nice square
for the knight if possible and here we
have Bishop to d6 Janoski has some plans
of bringing this rook into the game via
rook to e7
but also it's a lot more active Square
for the bishop but this Bishop already
played plenty of times in the opening so
you don't really want to waste more time
rema NuvaRing there are other pieces to
bid but to be developed but it's not
that easy you can't really develop the
knight then you allow this knight to c6
so general ski tries it this way
we have Bishop 3 to Capablanca prepares
the castle Bishop to e6 and now we have
Bishop to f3
as you can see black has an isolated D
pawn Capablanca blocked it with with the
night that's how we do it if there's a
nice light pawn first you block it then
you attack it and then you win the pawn
and then you win the game so here
currently the knight and the bishop are
pressuring the d5 pawn but you can also
sometimes you can go Queen b3 let's say
increase the pressure on the pond you
can bring this rook over to d1 increase
more pressure
the phone so it's hard to say it will
this game be above the deep on or about
something else
rook to a7 and now we have castles and
rook the c7 now so the rock is now
developed and occupies the open C file
Queen to b3 a kappa blanka the develops
his queen connects rooks and also
increases the pressure to the d5 pawn
and now finally black can develop the
knight as well Knight bd7 and the
Janowski was known to be a very fierce
player a very attacking player he's not
interested in any passive positions he
wants to attack and crush the opponent
quickly so here he offers the deep v
pawn or so it seems but you can't really
capture it if for example kappa blanka
plays Bishop captures it doesn't work
because well Knight captures and after
Knight captures you don't capture back
but first night the c5 you attack the
Queen force it back and now the Queen
also indirectly attacks the night so now
you can simply capture Queen captures
and now you capture an h2 with check
King captures and Queen d5 wins the
Queen so defending the d5 pawn were
would a tactic we have rook F to d1
my capablanca now all again increasing
pressure along the D file and now comes
Knight to e5 attacking the bishop on f3
kappa blanka of course of course wants
to keep it Bishop to e2 controlling the
c-4 square and now comes Queen to e7 so
what do you do here Capablanca brings
his last inactive rook into the game we
have rook 8 2 C 1 and Janoski does the
same we have rook F to c8 and now all of
the pieces rooks and everything is
optimally placed for both sides and
capablanca has to figure out how he
wants to go about this you can't really
get rid of this Knight let's say you go
f4 you want to bring the bishop back to
f3 to try and win the d5 pawn by force
but after a black puts a knight and c4
black is just better you're gonna have
to grab that night and then black will
already have a passed pawn on c4 and
it's a very well protected passport so
after rook have to see a cup of long
curses okay you have a weak b6 bone so
let's let's try attacking that couple
plays Knight to a4 and also he would
like to you know remove all the tension
from the C file and so he offers a trade
of rooks we have rook a person c1 rook
captures rook captures and now Bishop
captures and c1 and now comes nicely for
a very poisonous move as what's stopping
capablanca from capturing the b6 bone
that's the question so I'm sure you will
see it but just in case you don't if
capablanca plays Knight captures and b6
here
how does general skip punish capablanca
here and there's a there's a very nice
move that really points out to whites
you know a poisonous pawn queen Queen to
c7 attacks the pawn and the night ended
the bishop on c1 this is the problem
so after Knight to e4 Capablanca removes
this a liable there's up here Bishop to
b2 no longer can it be used as a target
on c1 we have Knight to c4 now and here
we have Bishop captures on c4 capablanca
gives away the bishop and now you could
play pawn captures on c4 but Janoski the
the attacking player that he is goes for
a different line Bishop captures on h2
and he starts an attack on the King side
against capablanca okay King captures
you do have to capture it and now we
have Queen to h4 check bringing the
Queen into the game as the night is
already controlling the f2 square
King to g1 and now comes Queen captures
an f2 so Capablanca saw this as soon as
Janoski put his knight on e4 but
obviously he calculated everything out
to do to the maximum King back to h2 and
now comes a queen a queen to g3 check if
you join offski once he can simply go
Queen to h4 check in g1 Queen to have to
check King h2 Queen to h4 check King do
you want me to have to check and force a
draw the draw by Perpetual but after
Queen to King h2 Queen to g3 was played
this comes with check we have King the
g1 and of course if you don't go king g1
if you try something like King - h1 then
you allow the Knights to enter the
attack and then it's all over
King g1 best for page 3 and you
you are doomed here so after Queen G 3
we have kinked G 1 and now D captures on
c4 finally capturing this Bishop and now
Queen to c2 bringing the Queen into the
defense at least you're guarding some of
the squares the black Queen can use the
harasser King Queen captures on e3 with
check King 2 h2 and now Queen back to g3
with check King Jiwon Queen e1 check
King h2 and now Queen back to g3 check
so as you can see if Janoski wishes that
he can still force a perpetual here and
settle for a draw which you know having
the black pieces against capablanca a
lot of players will do this but not Navi
Janoski we have king to g1 and now Queen
to e 1 check King h2 and now Janowski
retreats with the night with nice to f6
now there are again some very nice ideas
the knight can come join the attack via
Knight to g4 and this will come with
check but Capablanca takes this
opportunity to eliminate to one of the
attackers Knight captures on e6 and you
don't really have the option of
capturing back yes Capablanca is up a
piece but for now his extra piece is
still the night under in money for and
until he gets it back into the game it's
it's as if he's not up a piece so Queen
to h4 check King G 121 check King to h2
and now Queen back to h4 check repeating
moves a couple of times with King to g1
and now not capturing here because Queen
to c3 will be a very nice move for white
controlling d1 square which delivers
check and also pressuring this night as
there's this Queen Russia battery that
would be threatening checkmate and g7 if
no Knight moves
so after King g1 we have Knights to g4
again Janowski offers Capablanca to make
some mistakes
for example if he decides to save his
knight via Knight to f4 then the Queen
to e1 is instant checkmate as the F 2
and H 2 squares are covered by Chomsky's
night
so after Knight to g4 Queen to d2
Capablanca guards the e1 Square Queen to
h2 check King to f1 and now team to H 1
so as you can imagine it's
very hard to defend in positions like
this what the the site attacking will
always find ways to attack but it's if
you miss one single thing you you're
going down
so couple longer has to be very careful
with these King walks King to me to
Queen captures on g2 with check King to
d1 and now comes Knight to f2 with check
King to c2 and now Queen to g6 with
check King to c1 and now while you can
go on ice to d3 check first we have
Queen to g1 check repeating moves a
couple of times
seeing how kappa blanka breeds King back
to c2 Queen back to g6 and knocking to
c1 and here Janoski has to keep going
with this attack so night the d3 check
and now you don't really have all that
many options we have Kingdom b1 and now
finally capturing the night F captures
on e6 so what do you do here cuppa
Blanca plays Queen to c2 and now pinning
this night as the Queen on g6 would be
under attack and as we said cover Wonga
has an extra piece but for now the extra
piece is the useless night on a4 so
until capablanca brings it back into the
game it's really not all that useful h5
what you know ski has is a few a few
connected well not connected but these
two are connected this is a passport he
has an past H pawn of past Jeep on a
past epon and well it seems the past C
pawn that he created in the beginning of
the game so a lot of passports kappa
blanka has to deal with and all he has
to show for it is a stranded night an a4
we have Bishop to d4 capablanca now once
the capture the pawn on d6 and also the
bishop is very nice controlling the G 1
square and once the b6 bone is
eliminated a couple Blanca zone b-pawn
can start can you know start to go up
the board
h4 Yourofsky continues pushing his
passed pawn and here we have Bishop
captures on b6 you might think but why
not nightcap for some b6 you know
capture the pawn and get our knight back
into the game doesn't really work
because here the bishop on d4 is
undefended and you will use the Queen to
Reema
the Queen - a better square while
attacking the bishop also you are
already controlling the h1 square the
queening square so it's very dangerous
h3 Queen ji - and it would be very hard
for white for example a bunch of
characters on g7 Kim captures Knight
captures on c4 yes you equalizing
material and now you also have a passed
pawn but the black is just faster for
example h3 b6 you can go Queen h1 check
King has to go King TK 2 h2 now and now
doesn't really matter what you play
black is just a much faster Queen Eater
Queen captures you're also controlling
the b7 Square so not really possible
Queens you to check King move King b3
you will get another Queen now you're
really protecting that b7 Square and
even if white is able to deliver some
checks the black King will be able to
move and the two queens will be very
useful in guarding the King from checks
so after this h4 move we have bushel
capture some b6 the night for now is
forced to stay stranded on a 4 h3 and
now we have Bishop to c7 you have to
control the h2 square once this pollen
comes to h2 it's it's or it's all over
we have E 5 blocking the bishops well
influence over the h2 square and also
starting to push the e pawn as well we
have v 6 kappa blanka now starts pushing
his own past pawn and now we have Queen
to e for controlling the queening square
but also the b7 squares so kappa blanka
cannot push his own past pawn we have
Bishop captures on e5 a very interesting
move and also believe it or not on move
53 the critical moment in the game in
these older games like a hundred years
from now it's not very often that a
critical moment will be unmoved 53 so
here of course you cannot capture the
bishop with the night as it simply
doesn't work for example if you go
Knight captures on e5 then Queen
captures an e for your queen is
unguarded that will not go on the other
hand if Queen captures then you get
Queen captures on
c4 with check King f8 and now Queen
captures on d3 and now your extra piece
really means something and now if H to
you you're just in time to get
everything Queen f3 check King g8 and
now b7 your queen is defending the pawn
you're also defending the queening
square and everything is working out for
for white so after Bishop to e5 we have
the first Queen to e1 check by Janoski
now removing the pin and now Knight
captures and e5 becomes possible we have
King to a2 and now Knight captures on e
v b7 by Capablanca now we have 9th to d7
guarding the b7 square ago at the BH
square and now we have Knight the c5
capablanca offers his night so he can
promote this pawn into a queen of course
generals will not allow this he blocks
Knights the b8 and now we have Queen
captures on c4 delivering check you have
to move King h8 and now comes Knight to
e4 and now capablanca is well we could
say out of the woods he has his own
passport on b7 the Queen and Knight are
creating a wall here against the black
Queen so black Queen cannot deliver any
checks here so black has to figure out
what to do and also kappa blanka creates
a little trap here if black starts with
H 2 then Capablanca has a forced win
with Quinta CA to check King has to move
now you get Queen to h3 check King g8
and now Queen to East 6 check King back
to h8 and now comes Queen - eh check
King to h7 and now finally you get the
knight into the game Knight g5 check and
now after Queen 13 to h6 the Queen only
one is unguarded Queen captures anyone
and it is all over
so after Knight to e4 we have King to h7
first by general scheme you don't want
to allow any checks on c8 but now comes
Queen to d3 and now couple Blanca is
simply in a better position he's
threatening to capture the h3 pawn if
you lose this pond and really you have
nothing to show for and also you're
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
so you have to worry about
everything here and it's not all that
easy how do you protect the pawn if you
play something like Queen to h4 you get
tonight the g5 this is a double check
and now if you go for example King g8
you get Queen to d8 checkmate the knight
is controlling f7 and h7 and if you for
example go to h6 like taking h6 then
it's a different story
Knight f7 check the Queen is controlling
the light squares the King has to go
down the board Queen f5 check now if you
blocked with the Queen Queen captures
this checkmate you have to go g5 and now
95 an excellent move that will deliver
checkmate on the next move Queen to h7
is a move you cannot defend against the
night control c4 so no checks are
possible here the Queen is controlling
this square so no Queen 2 f2 checks are
possible
black is just like it's just over here
so after this Queen to d2 remove we have
g6 blocking discoveries but now you have
to give up the h3 pawn and Capablanca
snatches that we are king capture the
Queen captures on h3 King to g7 and now
Queen to f3 again controlling all the
squares not allowing any checks to the
black Queen and also Queen to f6 is a
threat so Quinta c1 is played by John
offski he would like to play Queen to c2
and as if you know it's very hard to now
win the game you've lost your main
advantage th pawn but you could still
force a perpetual if you can get Queen
to c2 check in time so Queen to f6 check
by kappa blanka King to h7 and now we
have Queen to f7 check and now if King
to h8 this leads to a force checkmate
Queen F 18-gauge 7-9 to f6 checkmate as
the Queen is controlling age 6 and after
Queen to f7 check King to h6 was played
now comes Queen to f8 check again you
cannot go up the board because of Knight
f6 check you have to go down the board
this is covered by the knight King to h5
we have Queen to h8 check King to g4 and
now finally you see which move ends the
game I'm not gonna ask you to pause the
video because you must see it
use the whole board of course it is
Quinta ch-check congratulations to
everyone for seeing it as everything now
connects its check
also the Queen on c1 is under attack it
was in this position unmoved 66 that
Davi Janoski resigns the game as you can
either move the King and lose your queen
or you can capture upon promote the
Queen now with check moves Queen
captures with check and now you are up a
queen and everything is all over here
but yeah a very interesting game by both
Capablanca and Janoski Janoski had a
brilliant position he created a very
powerful attack he could have drawn the
game plenty of times you know he had
like a lot a lot of possible position
where he could just force perpetual
checks and force a draw but he wanted to
beat capablanca I don't think it was a
matter of pride or anything it's just
that the table Janoski is not kind of a
player who plays for a draw kind of like
a Mickle tall thing you know but much
much you know 50 years before tal was
even tall so definitely an excellent
player and you know we should be we
should be thankful to players like
generosity who created games like these
and created possibilities for games like
these to even happen but as the title of
the video suggests not everything is
always as it seems for if you remember
that moment where we mentioned we're
after h4 we had this cup of lanka
captured we had h3 and then after a
couple of more moves you had this Bishop
captures an e5 move and okay we
mentioned you can capture with the night
you can capture with the Queen so
instead janowska played Queen e1 and
captured the night then but there was a
different move a move Capablanca both
Capablanca and Janaki missed for some
reason I don't know maybe kappa blanka
didn't miss it may become a blanca saw
it but he didn't have any other chances
other them too
maybe hope Jon offski misses it but this
was in 1911 it was a very strong
tournament already move 53 you are you
know at your home it's Friday you know
perhaps you're just chilling or perhaps
you just returned from work and you
would like to enjoy a nice puzzle you
know really ponder upon this position
and find the move both
the mist that wins the game for John of
skin now I will give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are truly an amazing player as most both
of these two players missed it and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move both of them missed was
actually not Quinte one check between
two eight one check and of course now
that I've said that there was a move of
course all of you thought but what about
Queen to H 1 the difference is now after
the King moves for example King to a 2
now after Knight captures the same idea
no longer applies because now there is a
great threat the queen is on each one
instead of an e 1 and that from e1 the
Queen cannot get the G 2 and since you
all love the green square there it is
but from H 1 the Queen can very easily
come to G 2 and if Queen G 2 is played
the game is over so there's an there's
no way to prevent it for example Queenie
to immediately Queen to G 2 is here and
there's no way to prevent it Knight c3
you defend the Queen but now Queen
captures and Knight captures and now H 2
and after b7 you get nice to d7
protecting this and then white simple
place like the g3 protecting D H 1
square and now we have this endgame
where black is just two pawns up it says
it's a rather simple endgame the black
king will simply go over here pick up
this pawn and enjoy his material
advantage and win the game so for some
reason either either kappa blanka didn't
even consider that move or he considered
it and saw everything and thought maybe
I will just hope Janoski doesn't see it
maybe Janowski after Bishop captures an
e5 just just a thought yeah Queen e1 is
also winning so I don't know but yeah
king a queen - h1 definitely the only
move that wins and in fact you know
generosity was correct and not to pursue
pursue professional checks and go for a
draw but he had a very nice position
where he could have crushed the great
Cuban
so I do hope you enjoyed the game and
that you are enjoying the you know the
entire Capablanca saga so far and as it
says in the top corner up in the left
the game changer result it is a book by
Natasha Reagan and the Matthew Sadler
about alpha zero saying the game changer
means that it will change the way we
perceive the world so this is not this
is not like a sponsored message or
anything I was just very much looking
forward to this book coming out so in
case any of you are like me you know if
you were hoping that it would come out
today it comes out so you are welcome to
acquire it I still haven't read it I
will buy it today offer to send me a
free copy I declined it so you know I
can easily say that nothing on this
channel is ever sponsored I only promote
things I myself enjoy so I will I will
buy the book myself it might even be a
bad book I don't know so I'm sorry if
you acquire it and then it turns out to
be a bad book but I don't think it is a
bad book as the both of them Natasha and
Matthew have been working with alpha 0
from the beginnings and they are both
strong chess players so I think it will
be a very nice book but yeah
I do hope you enjoyed that as well I
would like to thank Paul Muscat the
Benjamin Davidson Carmen Morris and out
of Harbor and alone Tanaka phone for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous videos so
you're thankful for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting videos I'm going to an early
party today so I don't know if I will be
able to cover any Tata Steel games as
they are being played but if there's
like a really crazy game I will come
home from the party and make a video on
it and then return to the party so yeah
thank you all and I'll see you soon